so now you would think you would think
that people would just see this
beautiful garment on the on the World
Wide Web and you just admire it kind of
doesn't ran a look lovely
but of course they can't they they do
compare it as you said to this they also
they also turned it into a perhaps most
delicious of all against his beef slice
[Applause]
okay Aussie go Joffrey Cersei Ilyn Payne
the mountain beric Dondarrion
Sarris of man the red woman
Tom Hanks talking of air pumped up you
get to wear the suit yeah which is a
nice you know kind of like I'm wearing a
suit yeah yeah well it's look like a big
red body condom yeah but Josh like but
it's really you that like hey hey it's
just a team of people to get that thing
on always like so terrified all like
throw up in the mask or something like
that is weird
oh yeah scratches that you just ya know
nothing there's nothing to count there's
no space in that thing at all when I put
it on I can actually taste my own
genitals it's disguise space
[Applause]
don't now slam me on my thank you
[Applause]
a few years ago there was I was in a
land rover parts department near
Peterborough the kind of place you find
me almost yes and waiting for car parts
and car parts you guys hang around a lot
because you know to get a part of the
guy has to go half a mile to the back of
the warehouse and then come back again
and he brings it back and he says this
is this is a left-hand one oh you wanted
to write on one sorry I'll go it takes
forever anyway I was standing around
with with a group of guys and I could
see this guy doing that and he came up
to me after a while then he said excuse
me has anyone ever told you that you're
the absolute spitting image of that mr.
bean
well actually I am the actor who plays
mr. bean and he said bet you wish you
were this bizarre conversation in which
the more I tried to claim that I was a
person whom he thought I merely
resembled less he believed me but what
was funny was how was how close he
thought I was he said the resemblance
have you ever thought of doing any and
you know look-alike work like stag
nights and night long as mr. bean he
said because you could make an absolute
fortune so your mother a big fan but
Brad Pitt's that was the best night of
my life yes
[Applause]
slippers no yeah there was this auction
thing that happened and I said what they
called me and said would you you know do
you want to do you want to auction
something off right maybe sort of an
experience watching the show with you or
something and I was like okay if it's
lovely it's great to charity it'll be
for some you know some something yeah
and it'll be fine I get there when it's
basically like this what it's basically
it's the Oscars that there's so many
celebrities in this room and I suddenly
remember that I said that I would
auction something off and so the fear
grows so I was petrified out suit
petrified and then the person whose
table I was on as a friend and he was
being very kind and kind of put the
paddle up and I was like thanks very
much that's very sweet that'll be that
and then someone else's paddle up went
up across the other side of the room and
I didn't really know and then suddenly
it was sort of becoming a bit of money
and I was kind of thinking else's
absolutely mental and someone went it's
Brad Pitt Rieman he's so cool to see
this from the different angle is what I
I can't watch this it's fine there's one
clip but I will warn you it's not for
the screen
no see I'm wearing two wires they're
basically just safety wires because I'm
I go at a full tilt and I'm sprinting as
hard as I can and I hit the side of the
wall and that's the stunt I hit the side
of the wall and then I'm chasing after
Henry actually and all his fault I blame
him
my hit decided the wall and then I climb
up on the wall and I'm supposed to run
past care okay so we've got this is the
shot from behind you so this is you see
the the speed and the momentum of the
run and it's in London there we go
so it's keeping me okay so here he goes
do that
but you get my point you think how did
you break a leg so let's hook it up to
the side just list it from the side so
this is from the side here we go we shot
it with three camera okay here he goes
and now now we've got a camera which
focuses on the foot now if you are
squeamish don't watch this show it to me
and I'm like yeah
I mean if bone doesn't pop out or
anything but it is an odd angle for
anyone's foot to be but you never have
to do this yeah we go here we go oh my
gosh
so he jumps that speed that momentum
here we go
and watch that whatsit here
here is why here is why Tom Cruise gets
paid the big bucks okay because this is
it from the front angle okay
so you've just seen what's happened to
his foot now watch this I knew I broke
it instantly to town now anyone else go
well that's over No
[Applause]
just run ahead performed on her teeth
take it away
yeah about this I've not seen it this
[Applause]
just over his head
you guys then excuse my excuse my
buttocks
look at that thing oh my golly hey Jeff
you can post it on Facebook the Sun is
the lowest form of humor true or false
but can you give us a blast of like a
hit will no can I just say feel free
because we really won't know if you've
got it wrong rookies susu can become
bazooka - and nights all miracles are
taken Isaac God he's shown him it's a
kunai
[Applause]
there's a fly drowning in your beer that
flies live so you might I did watch and
is there any chance like because
presumably no one's I'd like to come on
and change that seminar I would drink a
beer that had a flight and enjoy wrong
with my finger yes the fly yeah course
well no flies anyway go on Lord of the
Rings
now continuity sorry Justin
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we're gonna be alright
[Laughter]
[Music]